my mother passed away um she was
actually uh killed by her um her new
husband oh my gosh um they were both in
their late 70s um and they um they left
me with quite a bit of money I had never
uh I never made more than about 85 Grand
a year and then was left with a couple
million dollars and I I hope I've been
doing the right steps and I assume he
the uh the husband's been put in jail uh
no he killed himself afterwards oh and
you're still working making 80 no I I
haven't been working since the day she
died oh wow okay an important part of
your recovery moving forward is you're
going to have to get uh you're going to
have to get a job yeah you're going to
have to get a purpose a thing to do a
thing to go to a thing that you are a
part of that the world's going to be
better because you were a part of it